when you're in daydreaming mode you
start to do a little bit of the lateral
thinking so you start connecting this to
that to this and you start to go through
the aha moment find a need in the world
that can be served by your passion but
again once in a while my friends we need
to be willing to make a mistake we need
to be willing to fail it is only when we
risk making a mistake that we might find
ourselves improvising inventing
innovating our way back to where we want
to get to need motivation watch a top 10
would believe nation what's up at 7 my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from having an obsession as a teenager
with filmmaking and documenting to
becoming a TV personality a speaker a
filmmaker whose goal is to use
technology to help excite people about
philosophy and science he's Jason Silva
and here is my take on his top 10 rules
of success enjoy
[Music]
all right kicking us off number one is
create your flow state tell me about
your process your ritual how you are
able to come up with these a stream of
conscious riffs I started getting into
this idea of flow States because I read
this article that talked about doing
brain scans on freestyle rappers when
they were improvising and then they did
brain scans on them when they were
reciting memorized lyrics and what the
studies found a part of the brain that
is responsible for our self editing our
sense of self-consciousness that part
goes dim during the freestyle so
essentially you're getting out of your
own way and it's like that line in black
swuan that says perfection is not just
about control it's also about letting go
so I can have all my notes and my
thoughts and my ideas and this nap but
that's then I go for the walk I go into
the woods I go to Sea Ranch California
to go to Big Sur I go to some Park and
this the stroll and the disconnection
from distraction gets your brain
daydreaming when you're in daydreaming
mode you start to do a little bit of the
lateral thinking so you start connecting
this to that to this and you start to go
through the aha moments if you are lucky
enough to have the camera
you're capturing that real-time floor
it's creativity happening in real time I
mean it literally feels like channeling
so for me I figured out how to create my
flow State and the results tend to be
these riffs that people really love and
they're like why there was no script
that was a completely extemporaneous
stream of consciousness
I'm normally kind of an introvert and
I'm kind of shy in most social
situations but if the conditions are
right like a flame it emerges we never
have a true accurate rendition of
reality because it's all about our
perception our projections our longings
our romantic partners our creations and
we are the creators so you said if you
can create that flow state how do you
create it I have found that the best way
is to take yourself out of context so a
new experience a new space in the new
place so that I transcend what Michael
Pollan calls have been theirs and done
that's of the adult mind and I can enter
the consciousness of the child I can be
in wonderment I can be curious about
everything around me so rest relaxation
novel spaces novel environments
disconnection this connection from me
everyday this connection from your daily
responsibilities disconnection from your
trivialities just a daydream space a
space to dream to
cognition injury what happens when you
don't achieve that flow if it's not
working I become just highly anxious
actually irritable is probably the best
word I just kind of retreat I just wet
withdrawal can you describe how it feels
to be in that state it feels like
unbelievable lucidity instant recall you
know just this capacity to explain what
you're feeling and what you're thinking
effortless do we love harder do we
squeezed tighter you just feel your best
and you perform your best the minute you
choose one thing you've effectively said
no to everything else and there's a
gnawing anxiety and realizing that you
can't possibly have it off unlike a
reality hacker I'm like literally
attacking my ontological reality and I'm
studying how to trigger certain moods
and modalities I'm literally playing
with my consciousness so that I can feel
how I want to feel when
as often as possible how important is
this ritual of achieving that flow state
hugely important you are building the
foundations for something magical to
happen the ritual is as important as
chopping the wood and making sure it's
dry before you light the fire is
providing the necessary ingredients for
your cognitive salad it's very very very
very important almost I would say that
it's everything
[Music]
rule number two distort reality
brilliant people people will change the
world leaders right are said to have
this thing known as a reality distortion
field right Steve Jobs was made famous
for his ability to distort to italicize
perception in his in his co-workers
right to inspire somebody to see the
world in a new way right
- literally engage the attention of all
these body minds and present with them
an alternative universe to make people
to bring them into your world to suck
them into your trance right and
literally engage them to probe the
adjacent possible right - not that
shadow future that hovers over the
present that provides a map of all the
ways the present can reinvent itself
that's what leaders do they distort
reality but here's the thing there's
nothing fake there's nothing in
authentic about distorting reality
because the distorted reality becomes
real along with that perception becomes
the main operating system the moment you
adopt that vision as truth it becomes
true mankind decided we will fly it
became truth mankind creates technology
that holds space and time so the minds
can communicate instantaneously across
digital screens somebody hallucinate
AddThis technology into
where our thoughts spill over and if
they can harness the the will of the
people around us we can label new
realities into being we can usher walls
into being we can offer realities
because we as human beings our greatest
potential is that we have this reality
distortion field we are like neo in the
matrix when he sees the code and he
flexes his muscle and space and time
warps around powerful men rule number
three quiet your surroundings you need
to practice a kind of stillness right
like in order to induce contemplative
introspection you need to be you need to
quiet your surroundings you need to be
in places I think that are serene you
know I love a sort of an open natural
landscape you know a snowy landscape big
mountains you know I find that the outer
reflects the inner what is without
becomes within it's the power of design
spaces like wherever you put yourself
that's who you become what you behold
you are where you are so open spaces
majestic spaces trigger introspective
thoughts trigger inner vastness outer
vastness triggers inter vastness and I
think this I think that's huge huge huge
and I think people don't often don't pay
attention to the the poverty of their
surroundings and I'm not talking about
there's material poverty because the
poverty and the choice of what they're
surrounding them what selves with yeah
rule number four is find your passion
find your passion follow your dreams
figure out how you can make a
contribution with your passion but I get
it not everybody can immediately know
what they're passionate about there's so
many options there's an infinite
boundless menu of possibilities Timothy
Leary talks about the vertigo of freedom
there's so much to do I don't know I'm
paralyzed you're paralyzed I get it it's
overwhelming the paralysis of choice
open up Netflix how many times you spent
browsing for 20 minutes and then it's
like I want to watch anything
okay no matter what you choose is not
gonna be the right thing it's up so uh
you have to figure out this this passion
thing from all the possible ways in
which you could invest yourself Steven
Kotler also from the flow Genome Project
wrote this article in Forbes that I was
like holy Sh he deconstructed passion
here is the formula here's how you find
your passion if you don't know it you
make a list of 15 things that you're
really curious about right elizabeth
gilbert who wrote Eat Pray Love often
talks about the pressure of knowing your
passion and she says if you don't know
your passion at least chase curiosity
because at least you know things you're
curious about them you can make a list
so Cutler goes on make a list of fifteen
things are curious about so let's say
I'm curious about space I'm curious
about existentialism I'm curious about
the singularity like you make a list and
then you have 15 things now what you're
gonna do is you're gonna try to sort of
create a Venn diagram and you're gonna
find out where these things overlap
where to three to five of those 15
things you're curious about overlap
alright cuz now they're spilling into
each other see anything you're curious
about is squirting dopamine so it's
already there's neurobiology there right
but if you have multiple things that
you're curious about overlapping that's
a lot of neurobiology right follow the
chemical trail you know like we are
mediated by neuro chemistry our
ecstasy's and our sadness is all
mediated by neural chemistry so just
chase that dopamine hit but be smart
about it you know not the slot-machine
style dopamine hit but like here's a lot
of things I'm curious about here's where
they overlap that is the way to your
passion clear easy follow along and you
get it then he says now you know your
passion or at least the direction of it
find a need in the world that can be
served by your passion right because
then it's like you have curiosity which
leads to passion
the passion that leads to purpose oh
yeah
reason to get up in the morning eze on
betta a reason for being a reason for
moving a reason for taking action a
reason that matters a reason that makes
you matter curiosity passion purpose and
guess what you know what your flow is so
you can also bring insights from that
idea right so these are the things that
give me flow these are the things I'm
curious about these are were these
things I'm curious about overlap and
they overlap in ways that if I go this
direction I can also be in flow when
those curiosities overlap wholly and
there's a purpose that I can serve by
being in flow playing with all the
things I'm curious about and serving a
need in the world oh my god you've
figured it out that's it done go home
bye like that's the solution rule number
five is risk failing Isaiah Berlin
famously said to understand is to
perceive patterns that's in essence what
creativity is Steve Jobs says creativity
is just connecting things but in order
to see patterns and rather in order to
recombine existing patterns into new
forms and new shapes you need to be
willing to blur the boundaries between
your thoughts right to be an
associational thinker right it's a free
style to ride a butterfly affecting
thought but again most of the time we
play it safe right we map out what we're
gonna say we pre plan what we're gonna
do we make a list we have a set of steps
we are prepared we've pre-scripted our
speech right we are responsible we're
not going into a situation blind but
again once in a while my friends we need
to be willing to make a mistake we need
to be willing to fail it is only when we
risk making a mistake that we might find
ourselves improvising inventing
innovating our way back to where we want
to get to do you understand what I'm
saying
think of this rant as a metaphor for the
creative process right I
have somewhat an idea of what I want to
say right it's related to creativity and
it's related to cognitive dissonance and
being willing to make a mistake that's
all I know then they start jamming about
this and what happens is I might lose
myself in some chain of thought right I
just kind of lose myself in the moment
the metaphor might like confound me and
before I know it I don't even remember
what I was saying but somehow that's
when the creativity kicks in because
somehow I've got to bring it back I've
got a rope it in I've got to remember
where I'm going I've got some
incoherence right in the Bardot's
between one statement and the other and
in doing so and in risking screwing up
the video and the tape it is in that
risk that the courage that the
innovation that the creativity that the
original thoughts might emerge and
usually does and before I know it I've
landed and I feel like wow man I just
took a trip man you know I just sailed
into the great unknown and I brought it
back and here we are
that is what creativity is all about
that is the risk that is there be the
willingness to fail and make a mistake
that is crucial to the creative process
rule number six my personal favorite be
kind my mother is like this brilliant
artist poet sculptor teacher she's
taught for 35 years internationally
she's published like 10 poetry books she
directs theater and has directed theater
for many years and as well and and
around the world and you know I grew up
in the environment where the arts were
celebrated were creative expression and
expressive discharge was celebrated and
she always used to say just do what you
love do what you love do what you love
the only cardinal rule is you have to be
kind so it was like that was like you
know in terms of like the rules like you
just have to be you can't be unkind
you can't mistreat anybody ever but
aside from that kind of like abiding by
that you know everything else is like go
for it like express yourself dance like
no one's watching you know like just go
there and rule number seven is take
control of your life a lot of people go
through life thinking that they don't
have any
that life is just happening to them
that's not true
you know we we have a lot more control
than we realize you know and this
extraordinary control comes from the
power of feedback loops
you know you literally can decide can
almost author an afternoon into being by
planning to meet in a certain place with
a certain person listening to certain
music drink and a certain kind of wine
see it's like you know I haven't decide
that I'm going to see the world through
rose-colored lenses I'm going to be
optimistic I'm going to look for the
beautiful and every possible experience
that intention that agency coupled with
action right with editorial discernment
than saying okay I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna hang out with this person it
creates a self amplifying feedback loop
in other words the the intention to be
optimistic makes me stumble upon all
these things that make me feel more
optimistic and so on and so forth and
there's always gonna be the wild-card
there's always going to be the the
circumstances you can't plan for there's
always the unexpected relevance and the
serendipity but you know just like that
book the power of pull talks about we
can funnel the serendipity or we can
channel the serendipity funnel we can we
can help engender and engineer
serendipity by the choices that we make
every moment right and so you know by
cultivating rich social networks by
cultivating weak ties not just close
ties but the weak ties by becoming
connectors and by connecting others so
that they connect us we create a world
in which these self implying feedback
loops feet on top of each other so you
know good circumstances lead to other
good circumstances which lead to other
good circumstances and each one of them
it encourages us to then live more
openly and participate in that creative
flow space and you can go on and on but
that requires it requires a boldness of
character as well because the
realization of the dizzying freedom we
have to compose our lives you know if I
can do anything right it can be
paralyzing but I think that if we are
able to courageously embrace the
uncertainty of that freedom and then
exercise you know discerning and smart
and refined creative and linguistic
choices every step of the way we do have
the capacity to turn our lives into a
work of art and why shouldn't we rule
number eight find the way to express
yourself I grew up in South America
actually in Venezuela
which not everybody knows yeah so I'm
left panniers but affect them and that
the being like fully bilingual and went
to an international school in Venezuela
and from there went to college in the US
where I double majored in philosophy and
film most philosophy classes were not
even that good but occasionally you had
a kooky professor who is like yeah if
it'd also be a barred philosophy of
space and time philosophy of the weird
and I always Adam enjoyed like deep
dives and the heady ideas yeah and
cinema was just an art form that I
always loved just as a passive consumer
as a watcher I thought that nothing
affected me the way cinema did and so I
wanted to find exactly I wanted to find
some way of in turn expressing myself
cinematically the way that I had been
and it to impact others the way that I
had been affected and so again the love
of philosophy and film and and a hippie
mother who was an educator who was like
study what you love don't be practical
just do your thing
rule number nine positively impact
people I mean it you know it certainly
is life-affirming
and elating when you come across
somebody who has resonated with your
content because what it feels like is
the opposite of fear you feel your power
to do good and that's awesome like
feeling not just not feeling your power
right this is not like I am powerful
feeling your power to do good feels
really good because it's like oh so I
guess I can do something about my
feeling of impotence in the face of
where the world is going with politics
or in the face of like whatever it is
that that gets you down but that but
that you can do good so you can respond
to that malaise you know you can respond
to the doom and gloom it's like I mean
it's either that or cower away and die
and so yeah I mean I guess yeah I mean I
think I want something similar to what
what you probably want is well
positively
people like to to be to be net good you
know that what what we do in the world
raises this stage for for others as well
you know that's that would be a goal and
rule number ten the last one before the
bonus clips take the hero's journey
jean-paul Sartre says everything has
been figured out except how to live so
perhaps the better question is not what
are we to do with death but what are we
to do with life life exists in
individual moments and it is up to us to
make sure that those moments are vast
interconnected and grant to make a
masterpiece out of life one that we
willingly live again and again for all
of eternity this is what we could strive
for and I love this idea this idea of
aestheticizing our lives of italicizing
our experience of turning our story into
the story of seeing the universal in the
specific and sort of aligning ourselves
with the archetype of the hero's journey
of trying to see a departure from the
ordinary in every single instance a
chance to learn something new a chance
to leverage obstacles and learn from
them and make people along the way they
can teach us something it's what the
movie Pray Love talks about quest
physics the physics of the quest if you
believe and you're willing to step out
of your comfort zone life will begin at
the edge of your comfort zone
able to treat what seems like despair
what seems like hardship as an
opportunity to reinvent yourself if you
transcend your own limitations as Steven
Johnson says the world is full of clues
and you can read your way through it if
you're able to turn your life into an
art piece if you're able to turn your
narrative into the UH narrative then you
become that hero you become the god of
your own life it's the archetype in
every film it is the Joseph Campbell
hero's journey and that's just rap
that's just a cool idea
now I've got some special Jason Silva
bonus clips but before that the question
of the day is I'm curious can you induce
a flow state do you have rituals or
habits a routine that when you do these
things it'll let you become in the flow
state to then go off and create great
work I'd love to hear from you please
leave it down the comments below thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love I'll see you soon and
enjoy the bonus clips
sleep is huge like sleep is huge you
know a lot of people who like yeah
whatever I'll sleep when I'm dead and
then uh sleep when you're alive and your
life will be much better yes I think 50
cent said sleep is for those who are
broke and I think when I was in my early
entrepreneurial days I used like yeah
sleepers for those were broke if you
want to like to make money and build
your business you gotta hustle and do
whatever it takes and then I was just
like well I'm actually getting fat I'm
exhausted I'm really angry yeah yeah
there's a lot of links between sleep and
mental illness people would have sleep
enough could suffer can develop anxiety
disorder and all these things so sleep
is huge for me and I like my mornings I
like usually my mornings to be like the
two or three hours to like drink like
some coffee
philosoph I like to do some songs I have
to do some exercise in the morning just
whatever like some push-ups and pull-ups
just kind of some quick get to get out
of the way have my breakfast to email
and then usually after that like around
midday by 1:00 I like to switch from
from that kind of caffeinated email
workout thing and then after that I'd
like to switch it and go into free free
association creative mode and that's
like let's go see a film or let's go for
a hike right yeah something that it's
about disconnection so the morning is
connect focus and then afternoon is
divergent thinking the morning is
convergent thinking afternoon is
divergent thing and I think that's a
good balance for me raise your standard
Apple at the core is core value is that
[Music]
passion
[Music]
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details